قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها تسحب
وحدتها من الضفه الغربيه لنهر دنبرو وفقا
لخطه اعدت للغرب وكان وزير الدفاع الروسي
قد امر امسى القوات الروسيه بالانسحاب من
الضفه اليمنى لنهر دنبرو واقامه خط دفاع
لها على الضفه اليسرى من النهر خطوه شكك
بها الجيش الاوكراني واكد ان هجمات قوته
هي التي ارغمت القوه الروسيه عليها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان لك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات ما
حقيقه عزم الرؤوس الانسحاب من خيرسون بعد
سحب قوتهم الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر دنبرو
واي دوافع ميدانيه وسياسيه جعلتهم يتخذون
هذه الخطوه بعد قرار سابق بضمها
لماذا تشكك الخطوه الروسيه وما واجهت ربط
الاداره الامريكيه نيات الروس وخططهم
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بنتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه للكونغرس
وكيف ستنعكس الخطوه الروسيه على مسار
الحرب في اوكرانيا وافاق التوصل الى حل
عبر المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
بين تاكيد ان روسيا وتشكيك اوكرانيا خطفا
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من غير سون الاضواء
في اخر مستجدات الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
ذلك ان الامر يتعلق بواحده من المقاطعات
الاربعه التي اعلنت روسيا ضمنها ما يعني
ان استعاده الاوكرانيين سيطره عليها ستمثل
بكل المعايير انعطفا مهما ضمن التطورات
الميدانيه والسياسيه في مرحله لاحقه ربما
الرئيس الاوكراني فولدومر زيلينسكي قال ان
قوته تتحرك بحذر شديد من اجل تحرير خلص
واراضي اوكرانيا كامله وان العدو لا يقدم
هدايا وفق تعبيره
لا داعي لها ومن دون مخاطر وذلك ارضنا
باكملها وباقل الخسائر هذا ما سيضمن تحرير
خلص وكل المدن
لتدمير مدينه خلصن بالكامل وقال بودويات
في تغريده ان الجيش الروسي يسعى لجعل
خلصونا مدينه تموت عبره
مراسل لصحيفه
الروسيه نشر صورا لانزال العالم الروسي
امس من فوق احدى البنايات الحكوميه في
المدينه
واضاف الصحفي الروسي ان الاعلام الروسيه
تختفت من المباني الاداريه في المدينه وان
شبكه الهاتف الجوال والانترنت انقطعت بشكل
كامل في الضفه الشرقيه لنهر لنبرو
المقابله لمدينه خصون
في الروايه الروسيه للتطورات بخرس قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها بدات
الانسحاب نحو مدينتين ميكو لايف وكريفيري
واضافتنا المواقع الجديده معده مسبقا وفق
الخطه المعتمده على الضفه الغربيه من نهر
دنبرو المتحدث باسم الوزاره قال ان القوه
الروسيه تصدق للهجمات الاوكرانيه في
المناطق الجنوبيه من
كوبيانسكو
اكثر من 200 جندي الاوكراني تم تحديدهم في
الاشتباكات وتدمير وعدد كبير من المعدات
العسكريه
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع سيكون معنا من
موسكو فيكتور
محرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس
الروسيه ومن واشنطن ريتشل ريزو الباحثه
الاولى في المجلس الاطلسي ومن بيروت سيكون
معنا العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
ونبدا مع ضيفنا من موسكو السيد
فيكتور
سيد فيكتور
حتى الان
ليست هناك مبررات مقنعه بشان اسباب
الانسحاب العسكري الروسي من
الضفه اليمنى
لنهر دنبرو من منطقه سبق ان اعلنتها روسيا
بانها من ضمن الاراضي الروسيه وضمتها
اليها
روسيا ويبقى روسيا
نحن اخرجنا المواطنين من الجانب الايمن من
نهر
حوالي
115,000 اخرجناهم الى القرم ومناطق راستوف
منطقه كريسماس دار حتى نؤمنهم وفي نفس
الوقت اخرجنا الجيش لماذا
لان القوات الاوكرانيات تقصف سد الكفته
الذي يقع اعلى النهر واذا تدمر السد
المياه من
الثدي ممكن ان تقوم باغراق تلك تلك
المناطق الموجوده في خرفان وعندها سوف
يهلك الناس وحتى لا يموت المواطنين
لا تتضرر المعدات العسكريه تحولنا الى
الجانب الايسر حيث المرتفعات التي يستحيل
اغراقها وهناك الجيش مركز في المواقع وسوف
يسيطر على الجانب الايمن اذا حاول الجيش
الاوكراني ان يسيطر عليه
يمكن ان نفهم من كلامك ان الجيش الاوكراني
استطاع ان يحرر بين هلالين هذه المنطقه
التي تعتبرها همم روسيا انها جزء منها
يعني الجيش الاوكراني استطاع ان يحرر
منطقه روسيه بالمفهوم الروسي
اغنيه بوديه
اولا هي لم تدخل الى تلك المنطقه
والشيء ببساطه روسيا قدمت فرصه للجيش
الاوكراني ان يتقدم الى الجانب الايمن من
النهر وعندها قد تستطيع
القوات
الروسيه فتح خزانات المياه في السد واغراق
القوه
ليس سحابا بقدر ما هو عباره عن فخ ينصب
للقوات الروسيه عفوا للقوات الاوكرانيه هل
هذا هو السبب الذي يجعل اوكرانيا والجانب
الامريكي ايضا
في هذه الخطوه
وايفون
اطلاق النار
السياسيه بسبب انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
اذا فهذا يعتبر هزيمه الاستراتيجيه عظيمه
للجيش الروسي ومن اللافته ان نسمع ضيفكم
الروسيه التي يتحدث عن حمايه المدنيين
لانه لن نكون اصلا في هذا الوضع ان
تسلم تسلم
هذا يعتبر انه اجلاء قسري الاوكرانيين
وليس حمايه لهم فيونا هيل مستشاره سابقه
قالت هذه فرصه للروس بان يعلنوا وقفا
لاطلاق النار احادي والبدء في المفاوضات
اذن فاذا شيء سوف نراقبه عن كسب من الان
فصاعدا هذه النقطه مهمه ان كانت هذه فرصه
لبدء المفاوضات سناتي على ذكرها ونقاشها
طبعا لكن همم انتقل الى الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من وجهه نظر عسكريه
كيف يمكن ان تفهم هذه الخطوه الروسيه وهي
التي تتخلى عمليه عن همم جزء من ما سبق ان
ضمته اليها وهو جزء مهم من خير صام
حسن انها ثالث مره يتم الانسحاب فيها في
المرحله الاولى حولك كيف كان الجيش الروسي
يهاجم صدام
المرحله الثانيه او الحاله الثانيه هي في
خر كيف عندما انسحب مقابل الهجوم
الاوكراني واليوم
الانسحاب هو التوعي بقرار من القياده
الروسيه
بقرار علني يدل على عده مشاكل ان كان على
صعيد اللوجستيه على صعيد العديد على صعيد
حتى العمليات العسكريه حتى ان طريقه اعلان
الانسحابيه طريقه فريده من نوعها هناك
جنرال يقول لوزير الدفاع بالانسحاب فيقبل
لحفظ يعني حفظ الارواح لكن سؤال يبقى ان
هذا الانسحاب هو يعني كبير جدا وعلني جدا
كي يكون هناك خديعه ولكنه مكلف جدا سياسيا
وعسكريه خاصه لرئيس بوتين كي يكون مجانا
ما هي المرحله القادمه التي قد ننتظرها
حسن كما يقال بالعاميه لا ننسى ماساه الا
اذا حصلت ماساه اكبر يبدو ان النهر
النيبرو سيكون هو الفاصل والحد بين الشرق
وبين الغرب ولكن انا اقول يجب ان نتمهل
لنقول كما قال ماريك ميلي رئيس الاركان
الامريكي ان هناك ما يقارب ال 20,000 او
30,000 في الجهه الاخرى من من النهر لا
يمكن سحبها خلال ايام خلال اسابيع مع
الاليات المعدله لها هل سيكون هناك قتال
تاخيري لتامين هذا الانسحاب هذه امور كلها
في عهده المستقبل ولكن تعتبر بالمعنى
الاساسي والمعنى السياسي ان تتخلى عن ارض
اعلنتها بمرسوم انها ارض روسيه خاصه بعقل
الرئيس بوتين تعتبر خساره سياسيه ولكن يجب
ان ماذا يحضر للمرحله القادمه وقد تكون
بعد هذا الكبار 23
بطبيعه الحال هذا ما سنناقش عن المرحله
المقبله بالفعل الرئيس الامريكي جوبادل
علق على هذا الانسحاب الروسي من خرسون
وقال
بدا الكرملين وكانه ينتظر نتيجته
الانتخابات قبل الاعلان عن انسحابه المذل
من مدينه
خيرسون هذا الكلام
للرئيس الامريكي جودا اعوذ هنا الى ضيفه
من موسكو السيد فيكتور
ما رايك بهذا الربط انتظار الكريملين
لنتائج الانتخابات كي يعلن رسميا عن هذا
الانسحاب الذي سبق انقلت موسكو انه اييي
او ضمن خطه معده مسبقا
بين المناورات العسكريه والانتخابات
اوكرانيا وما يحدث في امريكا ان هذا حديث
سياسي بحث وشيء الثاني نحن لا نترك قرصان
وقطاع همم كرتون لانها قطعه روسيه
الى الجانب الايسر من النار مؤقتا وهذا لا
يعني اننا تركنا»
نستطيع ان نرى ونكشف المنطقه
انظروا الى الخارطه قبل ان تقولوا هذا
وسوف تتاكد انه المنطقه التي تم الانسحاب
من هي منطقه صغيره وليست منطقه خلصون
بالكامل همم ليس علينا ان نصب الرماد على
رؤوسنا ونقول
ان كل شيء سوف نعيد كل المناطق وكل المدن
الاوكرانيه التي تركناها مؤقتا
ماده برايك لدى الرئيس الذي يربط بين خطوه
الانسحاب وهمم نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه
وكان الامر ملفتا همم بالفعل
معك كذلك
يجدر قولها اولا هناك تلك الفكره
بان هناك انقساما داخل الحزب الجمهوري
اليوم وهذا الانقسام هو بين الصقور
والمنعزلين من جناحي ترامب وكما راينا من
الانتخابات قبل بضعه ايام الكل كان يتوقع
موجه حمراء
هذا الوضع وهذا لم يحدث في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه
لا يمكن لها ان تتوقع شكا على بياض هو
ابتعد عن هذه التصريحات همم
ولذلك ما رايناه هو اولا الجيش الروسي هو
ليس
درجه من القوه كما ظننا سابقا وايضا الدعم
من الحزبين لاوكرانه هو اقوى مما اعتقدنا
في البدايه اذا لا استشرف اي تغيير في هذه
المرحله بالنسبه لدعم الامريكي وحتى الدعم
الدولي لاوكرانيا وهذا امر يعتبر جيدا جدا
ثدي الياسحنا عندما
اشرت قبل قليل الا انه علينا ان ننتظر
الخطوه التاليه اي نوع من
الخضروات المقبله التي يمكن ان تحدث او
ايه يفترض ان نتوقعها خصوصا اذا اذا قرانا
الامر من منظار امني او بالاحرى عسكري
وسياسي ايضا
حسن المهم اليوم هو في تحديد الاولويات
العسكريه التي تخدم المشروع السياسي
للرئيس بوتين يعني الانسحاب الى الضفه
الشرقيه من النهر هي تعطي حاجز طبيعي
لحمايه العسكر الروسي حتى ولو كان هناك
تراجع بالمعنى السياسي المرحله القادمه هي
مرحله تحديد الاولويات اذا انطلقنا من
الشرق من سباتهوف على سبيل المثال هناك
يبدو ان هناك اولويه للجيش الروسي الجيش
المدرع الاول يقاتل في هذه المنطقه
بالمطلق اذا كان جاهز لديه بين ال 400 وال
600 دبابه بانا 30 وال 50 الف جندي وبدا
يستعمل الرجمات التفريغيه او اس وان هذا
يدل ان هذه المرحله هي مرحله الاولويات
الاساسيه لمنع جيش الاوكراني من التقدم
المرحله الثانيه هي تحسين يعني اذا نظرنا
الى الخريطه
فتبيننا موقع مليتو بول يا اللي هي تقريبا
جنوب زفولوجيا هي المدخل الاساسي لضرب
الجسر البري بين الدمباز بين خيلسون هذه
المرحله هي المرحله الاساسيه تثبيت الوضع
من هنا قول الجنرال الاميري الروسي ان اا
ان الج- العسكر الذي سينسحب سيتم نشره في
هذه الاماكن وكانه يبدو ان المرحله
القادمه المرحله الدفاع ثابته بانتظار
تطورت معينه والتي قد تكون حسن ممكن
بمرحله لاحقه باب الى الموقع التفوقي اذا
الصحه التعبير ومن هذا الباب
للموقع التفوقي اسال ضيفنا من موسكو السيد
همم
الخطوه لافته همم
بالتوقيت السياسي همم سبقها الاعلان عن
امكانيه التفاوض او حذف الجانب الامريكي
همم لاوكرانيا كي
همم تبدي مرونه بالتفاوض حتى بوجود الرئيس
بوتن همم هناك الكثير من من هذه الملامح
التي بدات تظهر وجاء الانسحاب الروسي في
خضم هذه الملامح الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون
نقطه تفاوض هذا الانسحاب ان يكون بدايه
لتفوض الماء ولو غير معلن مع اوكرانيا او
مع الامريكيين على الاقل
اولا انت محق
الليل هناك
مع الاخرانيون لان اوكرانيا ليست دوله
مستقله هي اهداف في ايدي واشنطن والحديث
ممكن ان يكون معه واشنط فقط ولكن واشنطن
غير مهتم بوقف العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا هذا اولا الشيء الثاني ممكن ان
نتحدث مع اوكرانيا فقط عن الاستسلام ليس
هناك اي تفاوض اخر ممكن ان يكون مع السلطه
الاوكرانيه لانه الاوكرانيا تقوم
بوضع شروط غير ممكن همم بالنسبه لتحرير
جميع المناطق من القوات الروسيه وهذا
مستحيل تماما لذلك روسيا ممكن ان تبدا
بالمفاوضات مع اوكرانيا فقط عن موضوع عن
الاستسلام فقط بعد ان نحرر نيكا لايف
وعندما نقوم بقطع اوكرانيا عن البحر
الاسود تماما قطعناها عن بحر الازوت والان
يجب ان نقطع الطريق بين اوكرانيا والبحر
الاسود حتى لا تستطيع اي دوله ان تقدم
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا عن طريق البحر الاسود
او الوقود للدبابات والمدرعات العسكريه
همم صيدليه هل يمكن ان تكون هذه الخطوه
مقدمه
لتفاوض امريكيا روسيه حول مجريات هذه
الحرب ومالاتها في المستقبل
دعوني اولا ابدا بالقول اوكرانيا لا يجب
ان تستسلم ولن تستسلم هذا
ليس شيئا يمكن له اوكرانيا اول غرب ان
يكونوا مستعدين ليجلسوا حول الطاوله
للحديث في مفاوضات هذا الامر مستحيل صحيح
ان الولايات المتحده والغرب
كان قادرين على ان يعزز الدعم والتعاضد
لدعم اوكرانيا في ظل هذا الغزو غير
القانوني وغير العادل من روسيا وهذا سوف
يستمر هذا يعني انه اوكرانيا هي الان في
موقف ريادي ونحن هناك لدعمي اوكرانيا باي
طريقه ممكنه
من خلالها النقاش حتى بين الولايات
المتحده
وروسيا بالنسبه للمفاوضات ولكن الولايات
المتح ههه تاخذ المعلومات
وتتساعد في القرارات من قبل اوكرانيا لكي
يكون هناك محادثات ومفاوضات ولكن لن يكون
هناك استسلام قط
شكرا لك سيد ريتشر ويزو من واشنطن وشكرا
لفيكتور لتبكين الذي كان معنا من موسكو
وطبعا الشكر موصول للعميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي الذي كان
معنا من بيروت
حلقاتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]